it's February 4th 2018 so it's time for
another monthly update video I'm going
to talk about what went on in January
and what we've got in this short month
of February I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things that I
think my readers viewers subscribers
everybody else who might be seeing this
could be interested in and the first of
these has to do with the video channel I
am starting a new series of question
answer videos that I'll tell you more
about in the February section so stay
tuned for those the second thing is
those of you who have an interest in
sci-fi fantasy horror that sort of thing
you probably if you missed it you want
to get in on the free course that I am
offering in the reason IO Academy where
I'm taking the worlds of speculative
fiction series and offering the
resources that I provide to the
participants here in the Milwaukee area
to everybody worldwide online as well as
the videos and and I'm gonna build a lot
of other cool stuff for that big thing
number 3 is a long awaited class that I
am finally I think confident that I will
be releasing in in February and that's
the Aristotle categories of course I
know a lot of people have been asking
about that so those are the three big
things for the month ahead now alright
so what went on in January the month
started out in some respects a bit slow
and I didn't get as much work done as I
would have liked because I had a bit of
a accident I fell down at the bottom of
the stairs I didn't fall down the whole
stairs but I sprained my ankle and
banged up my shin pretty good so I
wasn't able to like stand up for the
track board and and it laid it put a
sort of derailed my my intentions to
begin exercising regularly as one of the
things I wanted to do this year but you
know by the end of the month
everything had healed up and my wife and
I have joined a local gym here and we're
exercising regularly so in some respects
that's very good
you know it adds energy in a certain way
but it also takes energy away from you
as well at least while you're beginning
but that's that so what about events I
did a talk here in the worlds of
speculative fiction series third year
that we've got that going by the way
if you're not already enrolled in the
free online course and you'd like access
to the resources the videos updates
about what's going on you probably want
to enroll in that we're gonna be doing
you know twelve twelve great authors
this year I'll talk about one of them
coming up in the February
I also did a by invitation only not
recorded session here locally in
Milwaukee for for a group on Simone de
Beauvoir talking about her philosophy
and her contributions did philosophy pop
ups and and ask me anything session
these are all online events they asked
me anything and one of the pop ups is
with YouTube live you can see the videos
for that if you're interested and the
other pop up is Facebook live these are
all sort of under written by my patreon
supporters it's a way of me being able
to give back to the community of people
interested in philosophy worldwide
because my patreon supporters help to
you know pay for the time that goes into
that and the thought so it's a way for
me to you know give something back like
I said and we talked about Plato's
allegory of the cave for the philosophy
pop was a lot of really interesting far
ranging discussion on that we had our ke
stoic fellowship meeting kicking off the
year well we're still working through
Senecas letters and I was on a radio
show locally here in the Milwaukee area
with River West radio called image for
higher talking about among other things
the allegory of the cave
HP Lovecraft speculative fiction
philosophical counseling
huh philosophy can be practical how I
got into philosophy in the first place
and then there was another podcast that
that aired that I think I recorded back
in December perhaps but
aired in January and that's the Paul
Kowalski podcast and we discussed a lot
of things entrepreneurship stoicism half
a lot again how philosophy can be
practical how I ended up in this sort of
line of work so I'll put links to those
below I also engaged in a lot of
tutoring and a good bit of academic
coaching and philosophical counseling
and coaching in the month of January a
little bit of consulting work a good bit
of writing I finally got our exes to you
know at TK what used to be my main blog
and it's gonna be my main blog again up
and running I'm writing a bit shorter
articles you know on it I think that
trying to write very long articles was
keeping me from actually getting the
articles out in a timely way a lot of
work doing stuff for stoicism today both
editing and planning and behind the
scenes some work with the stoic
fellowship I did some some work on the
half hour Hegel blog to getting things
updated since we've made some progress
there and got to work out a few other
writing projects that are much
longer-term in a book book stuff another
thing you might have noticed is that in
January I started contributing regularly
to the website or platform kora which
allows people to ask questions and get
answers and so I've been contributing
some of my own answers most of them
having to do with philosophy a few of
them having to do with heavy metal or or
other things as well
when people seem to like it so so that's
cool and I got a good bit of video work
done maybe not as much as I would have
liked I met my goal of six half-hour
Haegele videos for the month I did two
book review videos I was hoping to get
four in but I actually got two done so
that's good and a number of core concept
videos on Cicero's on Duty's great work
and stoic ethics of course the event
video I actually released a few older
event videos that I hadn't gotten around
to and did some personal
videos as well on on various topics
including why I like Cicero so much so
that's what went on in January all right
so what's coming up in February let's
start out by talking about events and
remember all of these times are central
time so if you're participating in an
online event you want to make sure that
you take account of the timezone
difference so Tuesday February 6th 6
p.m. at the Frank Weinberg library in
Mequon here in the Milwaukee area we
will be having the ninth session in the
quarterly series philosophers in the
midst of history I'm going to be talking
about Cicero Greek philosophy and the
fall of the Roman Republic everybody I
think probably knows I'm a huge fan of
Cicero so there's gonna be a lot of fun
Thursday February 8th 7 p.m. we'll be
having the what is it twenty fourth Epis
24th session in the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
we're concentrating on Fritz Leiber and
is far furred in the gray Mouser series
you know swords against deviltry swords
in the mid swords swords swords all all
over the place great stuff I've been
really enjoying rereading this stuff
preparing for that then a week later
Thursday the 15th at 5 p.m. we'll have a
half-hour hegel Q&A and discussion
session online video conferencing if you
want to ask me about anything Hagel
related German idealism
we often range into a lot of other
philosophical topics as well this is
open to the public and you don't have to
really know anything about Hegel to
participate it's something that is under
written by my supporters of the half of
our Hegel project so it's a way for me
to you know give back and
helped people out as they're trying to
study this difficult work which is what
it's all about
Saturday the 17th at 12 p.m. we have a
another ama session again under written
by my patreon supporters so if you want
to thank anyone there are the people to
thank for that literally AMA you can ask
me anything that you like so long as
there isn't you know profanity or
you know some sort of racism or
something like that in it I'll probably
answer the question Google actually does
a pretty good job filtering out that
stuff quite frankly then later that day
a little bit later on I actually have
something for my patreon supporters
philosophy chat which is much more you
know intimate video conferencing I see
them they see me we get to chat in live
you know in real time about the stuff
that they're particularly interested in
so if you're interested in in getting
involved in that philosophy yet you
might want to consider becoming a
patreon supporter that's one of the
perks at the at certain levels then
finally Thursday the 22nd at 6 p.m. we
will have our MKE stoic fellowship we'll
be talking about Senecas letters again
that you can see in the Meetup and that
is is a lot of fun we got really great
group for that meeting every month I
should man I should also add that we do
have two philosophy pop-ups coming up
this month but unless you're a patreon
supporter they find out about it at the
beginning of the month they've already
been informed when they're gonna be
you'll find out the day and time in my
social media and in my blog or exes do
you know etiquette and then the other
thing that I've got going on is I'm
giving a talk about do Dhamma you know
Socrates legendary teacher from the
symposium again for the same local group
that won't be video recorded by request
of that group and looking forward to a
fun discussion there so that's all the
events that
quite a lot doing all the other same
kind of work a lot of tutorial stuff
some some coaching and some counseling
some contracted work as well doing some
interesting things with with ethics you
know I am a consultant so I do some some
things on those lines with with various
clients by the way if you're interested
in tutorial sessions and philosophical
counseling or coaching or in bringing me
in as a consultant just go ahead and
email me at Gregg at reason IO and we'll
get the conversation started be doing a
lot of writing I've got a couple
different book projects that I'm making
some progress on as we speak and also
we'll be doing more writing in our exes
do you know at TK I'm gonna be I have a
piece coming out in Stoicism today a
little bit later this month on stoicism
and romantic love and dating sexual
desire all those sorts of things be
doing some stuff in the Hathor Hegel
blog I have got some pieces I've been
working out in the partially examined
life blog and in the heavy metal
philosophy we'll see if they come out
later this month but you know I will be
working on and that's left I'm also
doing some academic writing as well
gearing up for a few conferences
polishing up some papers that are long
you know they're not overdue in the
sense that anybody's waiting for them
but I should have had them out you know
in front of journals a long time ago I'm
also still working on that Aristotle
categories course so you sit you should
see that coming out sometime this month
in reason IO teachable Academy I'll put
a link to that below and of course all
the big announcement about the course
once it's actually airing I don't think
I'm going to be working on the Marcus
Aurelius course I know there's somebody
who keeps asking me about that in part
because Donald Robertson has already got
some stuff on that coming out and
because I have some other course
material that I need to get working on
before that
but you know I think it'll be more than
compensated by the other cool stuff that
I've got coming out in the reason IO
Academy the other things oh we have
videos right so this video channel I
should probably end on that working on
my half hour Haegele videos for the
month I've already gotten the reading
shot and and I'm getting these ready to
go I'm gonna do some more book reviews I
might do two or three this month I don't
know if I get really ambitious I'm 84
and I'm gonna do a few more personal
videos but I'm also starting those
answers to common questions and I'm
hoping to have some of those out early
this week what I decided to do is
there's the same questions popping up
over and over and over again online and
I thought it could be cool to have a
video that just addresses those and gets
sort of at the bottom of what these
questions are about and provide some
really well-informed the answer to it so
I'm gonna try to keep those at about
maybe you know five minutes tops
we'll see if I can pull it off or not
and then core concept videos I'm going
to be doing more on cicero's on Duty's
hopefully I can get some heidegger stuff
later this month and I might even do a
bit more you know it got me thinking I
don't think I have core concept videos
on the allegory of the cave probably
ought to do that probably ought to do
some other Plato stuff as well but we'll
see how much I can get done so that is
the month ahead that's all the stuff
that's going on hope you have a great
month and hopefully I'll see some of you
and these online or face-to-face events
you